[Music]
this guy was reported by his fellow
employees Omar Martin was reported by
his fellow employees who thought he was
so radical that he was a danger the FBI
interviewed him twice in 2013 I say
again again in 2014 Robert Spencer your
director of jihad watch uh you're out of
Boston I uh also joining me Peter Brooks
former CIA analyst and former deputy
assistant Secretary of Defense and Mike
Baker former CIA covert Ops officer
Robert what about the uh the fact that
this killer this Savage invoked the SV
Brothers in Boston and the Boston
Marathon bombing what does that say to
you well let it's clear that he meant to
emulate them that he meant to carry out
a Jihad attack that would terrorize
Americans in accord with the quran's
command to strike Terror in the hearts
of the enemies of Allah and to fulfill
Muhammad's command to kill gays and so
he was acting clearly trying to emulate
the tarv brothers he was a regular
attendee at the mosque he was on terror
watch list he dropped off the terror
watch list because the fact is there
just too many people like him to keep
track of all of them and that's exactly
what the Islamic State or Isis wants to
bring about they hope to have so many
Jihad attacks and so many Jihad plots
that the system will be overwhelmed and
collapse but what there needs to be in
order to for to Forstall that is an
honest examination and investigation of
what is taught in the Islamic Center of
Fort Pierce where he regularly attended
and was last there just two days ago is
that has anybody even cared to look into
whether the possibil whether he could
have learned his understanding of Islam
learned about Muhammad's command to kill
gays from that Islamic
Center I got it there very well said
Robert
Spencer the hope is it never happens
again let's go back to my three wise men
Robert Spencer director of jihad watch
Peter Brooks former CIA analyst Mike
Baker former CIA covert Ops president of
diligence LLC Robert SP give us your
last thoughts your most important
thoughts let's remember it's also
Ramadan and that Ramadan is a time when
Muslims increase their Devotion to Allah
Jihad in the Quran is taught as a
meritorious act that increases one's
Devotion to Allah and it involves Waging
War against got it I'm sorry I'm up
against the hard break I'm up against
the hard break I'll be right back